we just had our best look yet at
Hogwarts legacy's open world and just
how much we'll be able to explore when
the game hits in early 2023. the recent
gameplay showcase may have focused on
traversal around the open world but in
doing so the developers also revealed
quite a few gameplay elements we'll
encounter as we explore wait hold on is
that an enemy under the water here
swimming possibly confirmed when it
comes to open world video games fans
just can't contain their excitement when
they see a fast map filled with various
points of interest and places to explore
across a world they're passionate about
game director Alan 2 confirmed that
we'll have full access to explore fairly
early in the game after reaching a
certain point in the narrative and from
the moment the open world is open you
can go anywhere possibly even stumbling
into areas where you're way out matched
with your current gear and level you see
for months now fellow Hogwarts Legacy
YouTubers and fans on the various Reddit
and Discord Pages have taken all the
bits and pieces we've seen from various
trailers and the gameplay showcases to
piece together a number of different
maps that try and show just how big the
open world and Hogwarts itself will will
be they've already done a far better job
than I could at showing off the size and
locations of the map itself but this
video will be more focused on what we'll
be doing within this vast open world
that includes Hogwarts and the
surrounding Scottish Highlands you see
the physical size of the map is only one
piece of the puzzle here after all you
could have an enormous map in world to
explore but if there's nothing fun to do
within it what's the point Screen Rant
published an article in 2019 ranking 25
open World Games by their physical size
alone now their numbers weren't exact
and there are various scaling techniques
at work to compare across different
games but even so the article gives a
pretty good idea on just how big the
physical space is in some of these games
especially if you've had the opportunity
to play them yourself and know how big
the world's felt to you just a few
notable ones here from the list Legend
of Zelda breath of the wild at 28.9
square miles Red Dead Redemption 2 close
to the same 29 square miles GTA 5 31
square miles and The Witcher 3 at a
whopping 84 square miles more than
double GTA 5 there now as someone who's
played all four of those games and
beaten three out of the four I can tell
you that all of them felt like Fast open
worlds with plenty to see and do so even
though the Witcher dwarfs them all in
sheer physical size I don't feel as if
any of the others suffered by having
what is a significantly smaller map so
while we're getting more and more a
picture of what Hogwarts Legacy looks
like in terms of the physical map size
what remains equally important is all
the stuff that we'll be doing within
that map now in addition to the flu
flame icons we got a good look at
several others that give a few hints
about various gameplay opportunities
across the open world we'll start with
one of the obvious ones which is the
leaf icon here now this one represents
the puzzles that are left behind by
Merlin now I know a few of us out there
have thought that Merlin is going to be
closely tied to the ancient magic within
the game and I still think that's very
possible however in addition to this
Leaf icon we also see a dedicated
ancient magic icon here so this is the
actual symbol of ancient magic itself
it's the very same symbol featured in
the Hogwarts Legacy logo now this whole
area looks to be much larger than these
Leaf icons and not just a simple puzzle
I'm thinking these will likely be more
extensive ruins or even full-on
zelda-like dungeons to explore game
director Alan 2 even told us
specifically what will be rewarded for
the Merlin puzzles and the ancient magic
areas right in the gameplay showcase so
when you go out into the open world and
you see see those icons whether they're
on the mini map or on your map or off in
the distance those things are
opportunities to say like I want to
increase my inventory capacity their
puzzles left behind by old Wizards you
know that you can solve that actually
Grant you those if you see ruins off in
the off in the distance and you visit
them you might find Opportunities to
actually expand and learn about your
ancient magic we also have bee stings
throughout the world and initially I
thought they were all noted with this
claw icon and yet we also see a spider
web icon later in the Showcase right
here so it seems that at least some of
the beasts can have different icons as
for enemy camps and the poachers that
have already been confirmed for the game
Alan mentioned these characters could be
hoarding valuable magical resources my
guess is these locations are noted with
the skull icon one we see here this
would of course match up nicely with the
skull mask enemies we've already seen in
the various trailers when it comes to
exploration one mechanic that's already
been confirmed is the seeking out and
discovery of the various scroll Pages
we'll be able to collect and add to our
Field Guide after of course we find them
with the revelio spell these appear on
the map as a small scroll with a
question mark and I find it at least
somewhat peculiar to see these showing
up on the minimap I'm not sure if
there's some sort of dead magic here or
perhaps the use of a Felix releases
potion but it seems strange to me that
these would just be directly noted on
the map I mean right when you go by
perhaps we have to complete another task
or first find a clue before these icons
show up on the map or maybe you actually
go to these icons and then they tell you
somewhere else where you have to go to
reveal the page curious to see how that
one will be handled now directly behind
this first scroll icon we also get a
look at what appears to be some sort of
cave-like structure that is just begging
to be explored don't really know what
else to say about that one so if you
have some thoughts let me know in the
comments below a bit further in we see a
speech bubble icon which almost
certainly indicates an NPC we can talk
to and possibly even get a Quest from
speaking of quests I'm guessing this
icon here denotes the various side
missions we can tackle with the larger
one outlined in yellow possibly being
our main quest at the time during this
showcase the mini-map even showed the
exact location of Loot and treasure
throughout the world now this one we
know is an effect from Felix felicis as
this image and description here appears
on the game's official website it reads
use this potion to reveal gear chests on
the minimap for one in-game day
resulting in a particularly rewarding
Journey as you explore Hogwarts and the
surrounding areas yet another icon we
saw in the Showcase is this one here
which appears to be marking a graveyard
now what's interesting about this one is
just when we fly over we see a few
different red markers appear which could
indicate in theory possibly maybe
they've just appeared in this location
to attack now later on in this swamp
area we get a brief Glimpse at a
labyrinth-like icon possibly a maze or a
puzzle in the area and I have to say all
that we're seeing here leaves me very
encouraged so far when it comes to
Hogwarts Legacy and how it may compare
to other open world games during the
development for The Witcher 3 CD projekt
Red came up up with an open world
concept around a very specific amount of
time as it relates to player exploration
within the world as they carefully
monitored early play tests for the game
they took note of players and how they
interacted with different points in the
open world in a no-clip documentary they
referred to this as their rule of 40
seconds the concept is pretty simple as
a player you can travel in any direction
on foot in the open world and within 40
seconds or less you should encounter a
gameplay element that catches your
attention this could be as simple as an
enemy or two a cavern to explore a pack
of animals or an NPC in need of help or
a full-on quest it remains to be seen
how closely or if at all Hogwarts Legacy
will follow this specific rule but the
concept really helps to shine a light on
the importance of focusing on the
richness of the world itself instead of
only focusing on the size of the map and
given what we've seen and discussed so
far with Hogwarts Legacy I'm hopeful
there will be plenty to do and explore
now one key component that plays a major
role within open world video games is
just how you will Traverse through the
world itself and how quickly you can get
to various points of interest so in
addition to traveling on foot Hogwarts
Legacy has also confirmed broom flight
as well as animal mounts that can be
used both on the ground or in the air
brooms will provide a quick way to get
around the open world and include a
boost meter however they don't do as
well at Flying high without being
upgraded first they've also confirmed
mounts for the grab horn hippogriff and
thestral with the latter two having the
added benefit of flight in addition to
ground transportation the animal mounts
will not have a boost meter like the
broom but can fly higher right from the
start without any penalty and then there
are the flu Flames these are scattered
across the open world and within
Hogwarts itself they'll serve as our
fast travel points to quickly get from
point A to point B in the second
gameplay showcase they appeared as white
icons on the minimap prior to being
discovered once discovered by the player
and subsequently lit the icon
transitions to a light green you see in
addition to all of these icons we've
talked about Alan also mentioned there
will be some quests tied to the game's
day night cycle and of course missions
that happen at specific times of day
aren't unique to Hogwarts Legacy but
those sorts of missions always help that
world to feel more alive more believable
they've also can confirm seasonal
weather changes and much like the books
and films Allen said these are used as
narrative markers to show visually how
we progress through the story throughout
this little exploration scene in the
gameplay showcase we also encounter
several different enemy types including
goblins and wild beasts such as mongrels
or spiders which by the way it totally
looks like the spiders are chasing down
the cattle to attack here I mean this
has to be more brutal than AK or crucial
if we can actually witness spiders
attack and devour cows in this game no
way right no way I mean we do see the
cows kind of takeoff running so
hopefully they're pretty fast but
speaking of those unforgivable curses
how exactly will they work in Hogwarts
Legacy the second part of the Showcase
focused on combat and I have a video all
about the unforgivable curses and how
they were used in that scene ready for
you next here on the right side of your
screen as always thank you all so much
for watching I'll talk to you again soon